Hans another Victory a tense game but
complete mad scenes towards the end of
the game what happened when Sam picked
the king I was just misunderstanding
nothing nothing too serious we had a
quarter conversation after so I assume
this is no hard feelings there but just
a misunderstanding so it wasn't just an
instinct to pick the king and start
twirling it it was he wanted to get your
attention like what was his well I think
the the pin of the piece was the king
had fallen off uh-huh so you just picked
it up but I was just a bit annoyed
because it was on my time but again I'm
not there's just no need to discuss it's
just a misunderstanding so and you guys
discussed after the game and there's
there's no no it was just a
misunderstanding misunderstanding I
don't want there's no no drama
I know you guys are desperate reviews no
no no no no drama but why he said let's
go and speak or something sorry because
it seemed like he said like let's go see
something to you at this point yes well
he wanted to do towards the house again
again it's misunderstanding but the he
wanted to glue the piece ah so he wanted
to go and glue the piece yes again I was
just very confused so you got it okay
that makes a lot of sense right now okay
let's talk the chess is much more
interesting yeah absolutely let's talk
uh the game
that's a good idea yeah
talk to us about the game yeah so he
started thinking after after uh the semi
thrash which was just I guess he wasn't
expecting it um and he had a game
against Jeffrey so he repeated this line
with Bishop before and uh if I had not
tracked this that would be very foolish
uh I played Rook C8 and said which is
the best move but uh this was a novelty
as well well okay so much of a novel
okay I think it's relatively known if
you're playing this opening but anyways
uh in Jeffrey's game because if you play
Bishop B3 and it's not that bad but it's
very inaccurate but this is actually
quite a critical line so after Rick C8
he plays um G3 Bishop B3 only move uh
Knight H5 also only move these are all
only moves and I checked this this
morning uh Bishop B3 F5 G4 if this is
the first sort of uh place where F4
things can white has the choice the
white has Bishop A7 white has Bishop D4
and white has gh5
so those are the three kind of moves
maybe they're more but from what I
remember these are three moves and let's
say after gh5
that'll be the Top Choice take take
Bishop E7 Knight takes Rook f8
and goes Rook F1 and some some stuff I
don't remember the precise I think and I
think yeah yeah position is pretty good
for you yeah I think it's yeah I think
it's equals on a higher depth but uh
because I was checking it was equal
um this morning yeah
um so yeah a bishop D4 this is this I
remember this being quite challenging
yeah net F6 and I remembered H6 were G8
and it felt like he knew what he's doing
yeah he definitely knew but the Fanatics
wouldn't have moved him because he
started to think yeah H6 is what I
remembered and Rook G8 Rook G2 take on
H6 I didn't remember this specifically I
stopped after uh Rook um GH but I I
could just figure out that after King Y8
yeah 94 hg5 this has to be okay I just
uh the bishop on B3 shuts down the Rook
on A1 and the two Bishops combined with
the Rook coming to C2 uh should be more
than enough and then uh he played Rook
G2
and I I play Bishop C5 which yeah you
know he said yeah can we discuss this
after the game uh H6 but no no before
um instead of Bishop C5
uh H6 and 94 94 take take Rook C4 uh
Knight D2 Rook D4 and then yeah now Rook
D7
um and Rook D1 and I wasn't quite sure
how to UNT ah Bishop be for a while
that's a nice that's a nice little
tactic yeah I I missed that um I don't
think it's that's pretty easy to miss
but I wasn't after let's say not even I
wasn't yeah King F1 I was sort of weird
you know I wasn't sure how to untangle
my pieces
um but boy the computer says it's equal
um anyways um but I thought Bishop C5
was much yeah Bishop just felt much more
natural it's a very forcing and it gives
some opportunities to sort of mess up
because he could have played Bishop six
gf6 and 94 Bishop D4 and did you feel
like he's well I thought I thought I
thought I could all play him here um
um I I wasn't yeah there was Rick G3
Bishop B5 yeah yeah I saw this and there
was a critical idea about G3 Bishop B5
or D3 no no Rook G3 Bishop B5 Rook D3
King 795 take take Bishop B2 and I
repeat one average C1 which is critical
um yes so that's just the only detail
that you need to see in this in this
variation
um
because otherwise this is fine yeah so
he went this and I'm like what is this
what is going on yeah okay so so you did
not anticipate this move
I thought I don't think it was this was
not part of your candid movies no uh I
had there was many different emotions
that I felt after this movie Yes okay
Bishop takes so here I have I have King
uh E8 I have King E7 I um there was the
torture Cannon rules um I thought the
king is that was much more natural
he told me this after the game yeah if
Rook HG there might be Network F7 so
it's smarter just to to play uh Rook CJ
to avoid this take take Bishop A7 and I
thought Rook G8
um and steer
um or would you want to and I wasn't
sure if King if yeah now you might have
Bishop H5 but I thought the point was of
King D2 I could play Rook G2 and Duke I
can sort of try to pick up the pawn but
again it's it's sort of a race this is
what we discussed after the game even
but what black is obviously to be
preferred um so there are some concrete
ways but I my idea initially was Bishop
G4 and uh I thought if H3 the the idea
was to play Rook to d8 and uh now if
Bishop E3 I play bishoper 3 Rook G7 King
E8
and now I thought 95 was coming
um but maybe this is not as precise what
ah 95 years coming forward yeah
something like that yeah it felt quite
dangerous
um yeah yeah so and also even yeah so
like Rook b795 for example
oh
there's any four
yeah but anyways I thought oh yeah
that's that's quite smart yeah but
anyways I felt with uh with the bishop
and Rook uh the king stuck there had to
be some tactics because the Knight on C5
can't really move because always sort of
Rook takes C3 idea for example if
um instead of the Knight B7 there's Rook
C3 and Knight d8 Rook D3
which is quite critical um there's a
Checkmate yep and um and yeah so he
plays takes yeah tick yeah and this end
game is quite nice this rookie 8 check
is important to get rookie7 and I was
quite happy here
um you know B6 is an interesting I
wasn't sure this is quite a nuanced
position because I'm happy okay so it's
whenever you have these end games
putting your pawns on a square it's very
it's a very difficult thing to to sort
of evaluate because
that you just cannot see the future
um but I felt that with B6 it wasn't
really possible for him to play um
if you didn't play A5 immediately I
thought that A4 could be weakness so I
thought a6a5 would allow him to hold so
I thought B6 was quite nice
um he goes H6 yeah so this was great and
now my Rook is activating yeah King E6
Rook D3 yeah B5 yep okay Bishop yeah
okay
okay wow so Rook F4 can I just check
this so there's Rook at four
here four rookie two King D5 okay it's
probably not such a big difference in
Bishop G7 what is the what is the
difference I guess the direct is better
placed on G4 maybe there's some
and rookie eight uh okay okay yeah so
the rookie the pawns hanging okay it's a
small detail interesting yeah no I
record five felt very natural to me and
I also was trying to press on the clock
yeah okay yeah Bishop G7 I don't think
it's a huge difference okay okay yeah so
so let's yeah
yeah so this uh
um so here I played I played um
I played Rook F7 he played Rook I'm just
where did I where did I blunder king of
horn
before Oh my God I actually was playing
no wait with it so I have to take an H5
I have to take an H7 and I have to take
enough two what did you calculate here
this is just so confusing to me
it was so ridiculous like for example
let's start from the position where I
play Rock F7 like I'll I'll talk about
what I was like yeah so he plays rickets
Ricochet on 40 40. so he plays this move
I don't know even maybe one move before
I think Rook D7 yes rookie so here I
have so many days so I have Rook D2 I
have B4 I have Rook F7 so I was thinking
like Rook D2 Rook h8 Rook F2 King G3 and
I thought check king of three take
there and I thought and I wasn't sure
because I was like okay let's say okay
before Rook h8
and
I guess the computers I just I don't
know I I guess I just got in my own head
here this is this is probably the
simplest um I just yeah I was just
too afraid didn't have the nerves here
but again I was like thinking oh maybe a
fade is coming
and I thought how do I win like
everything's covered I guess you just
have to go for despawn and then yeah and
then I just go for the pawn yeah I guess
yeah it's not easy yeah it's funny I was
looking at this but then so when I play
in the game I was also thinking okay
instead of instead of okay instead of B4
no no I play I play Rook G5 check yes so
let's go back I said Richard five so I
can play taken F2 and then King G3 and I
thought Rook takes B2
because I thought this working game oh
this freaking game is a draw okay I'm
just stupid yeah okay and and Rook B8
and B6 or B7 Pro yeah that makes so much
sense yeah okay
um okay I did not understand that and
I'm supposed to give a check yeah I
guess I just have to win the H2 and F2
pawns and I'm just winning but I I
thought like this was clever and they
placed he plays King H4 and I go Rook G6
yeah I just completely misevaluated this
this um but he has a very ridiculous
draw so the draw here yes B3 he has to
play yeah F6 and Rook H5
yeah that is did you guys discuss this
position after again it's funny we both
actually just missed even after the game
we just completely missed our cage five
yeah so at this point I think or
something should be going into that
variation so King A2 yes Rook B5 yes
Rook G6
Rook F5 now
and B2
it's a good question
[Laughter]
okay I guess I guess uh I guess that is
just uh
oh okay and you're not getting
checkmates I guess I guess um you know
uh I guess humans make these mistakes
though so by the way I think uh we might
have missed something like A6
oh my God okay this is here a little bit
of he had like no time but okay yeah
yeah I can I I knew I was playing very
badly but um it was not um okay so King
A2 and after this overwhile that is so
ridiculous so can we just go back to see
how could I so the critical mistake was
Rook G6
yes can you know all the way back hold
it back
surgery six and so let's say I play I
need to play Rook a five for kick seven
yes I play Rook F2 sure and he plays
King King G3 for example I have to play
Rook F7 Rook h8 yes
G4 instead King G4
or King G4 Rook F7 King G4 I just I
could not figure it out now Rook A1 sure
uh okay and I go around
yeah I guess I'm just I'm just you can't
calculate for my live streams yeah not
easy it looked very scary to me um and I
was struggling to figure it out but
options and so many weird things
happening I was getting I was just
confusing myself but yeah I should have
just been like okay I needed some of my
arrogance today to be honest I was a bit
too humble and it cost me what happened
four days ago when you came here you
said that you're going to come to Stage
a comeback and you did you just won your
last three games four days ago yes or
three days ago
after I beat uh we had the rest yeah
yeah well I think that um I have what
changed
well I think that I've just managed my
nerves better and um I think that at
some
early on in the tournament there was a
lot of pressure that I put on myself
um to perform
um and uh combining with outside
pressure I think it just sort of really
made difficult for me to play
um because I think that I can assure you
to everyone that playing chess as I said
during the singford cup playing chess
under sort of unique conditions or
unstable conditions is extremely
difficult
um but I think after I like lost three
games like an idiot I sort of realized
okay I'm not gonna win the tournament so
I relaxed a bit and I also sort of
realized you know I really hate losing
so much you know it keeps me up at night
so I wanted to sleep more so I decided
to start playing better chess
um and I also just hated the fact that
you know it's just I don't want to give
anyone the satisfaction of watching me
lose because I'm sure many people take
satisfaction of that
so I also take satisfaction into winning
and seeing people who want me to lose
weight so I took a bit of Spite and
motivation and okay you got to start
playing good chess yeah you can't be an
idiot forever
yesterday you said that the tournament
has been a disaster has the tournament
improved for you do you consider it to
be a success now no why would it be a
success
okay I've won four games which is very
good and if you
for any other player would be good but
unfortunately I lose I lost three games
which I don't think anyone has uh
so okay it's definitely I think it's a
success from from considering the
circumstances it's definitely a
significance discuss
um but of course I hold myself to a
higher standard and I expect more of
myself and I believe that this is uh not
even close to to my peak level of play
guys any questions uh just
congratulations on your win streak Hans
and we'll be seeing you in the ultimate
round tomorrow who's not sexually plays
tomorrow
okay I wonder I wonder I wonder yes so
how do you feel yourself I mean it's the
last round and actually today you
managed to stop same Savion now he's he
lost his surgery the job's not finished
you know how many games you need to win
to win an NBA series
I don't you guys aren't going to get
that joke but yes you have to win four
yeah four but the job's not finished
yeah okay all right all the best